- There's gonna be some
tough elbows in that race.
Let's just be very clear.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna get rough,
it's gonna be tough.
But I think at the
end of the day,
both gentlemen understand that
the country is on the line.
Who comes out of that?
Man, Joe Biden might as
well go ahead pack his bags,
I think it's gonna be over.
(intense ambient music)
- I'm Dave Ruben and joining
me today is a congressman
from Florida's 19th District,
Congressman Byron Donalds.
Welcome to the Ruben Report
in the swamp, man in DC.
How did we have to come all
the way down here to do this?
- It is work week.
You know, we finally
get back to work.
You know Dave, it's great
to be with you, man,
thanks for coming up.
- You're working
here in DC this week.
Everyone's here, everyone
and their brother,
they're trying to figure
all this stuff out, huh?
Leadership and Trump's now
in and it's messy, man.
- It's always messy,
it's politics.
I mean, when is a time,
gimme a time when it's clean.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Oh, that's just not the case.
Look, right now, this week,
everybody's swirling their
bubble and trying to figure out
who's gonna be in
what leadership slot,
are the Republicans at 218?
I think we got that
answer late last night,
early this morning with Kevin
Kylie out in California.
But you know what?
We're gonna get
through this stuff
and it's gonna be
back to business.
- So what are you thinking
about all this leadership stuff?
We were at the Senate
building yesterday,
I talked to a couple
of Congress people,
everyone's jockeying
for position.
Tim Scott, Florida, Tim Scott,
Senator is now gonna run against
McConnell for the Senate.
I mean, what do you
think is going on here?
- Man, I think it's good,
I think it's healthy.
Look, Mitch has been senate
leader for what, 10 years?
- 75 years, I think.
- I don't know.
- It's been a long time.
- He's also 80 years old.
- You know, I don't really
get too caught up
in the age stuff.
To me it's are you
have the ability,
the energy to do the job?
And as long as you
keep that standard,
I'm fine with how old you are
or frankly how young you are.
Because I think sometimes
up here on Capitol Hill,
people are like, "Oh,
well you just got here",
or, "Oh, you're really young."
You know, the Bible always says,
"Don't despise a man
because of his youth."
So I think it's really
about competence
and ability and execution.
It's good that Mitch
is getting challenged.
I know that people
tend to be like,
"Oh, well, how could you?"
Well, how could I what?
Every Republican
or every Democrat for
that matter that's up here
is because your people sent
you, they chose to elect you.
So if people, if we have
to go through that process
and battle for votes at home
and earn the support
every time from voters,
then we come up here, we think
it's all for acclimation.
I think that's wrong.
And that's one of
the reasons why
leadership frankly
in both parties
has caused issues for
the people of America.
So I think it's healthy.
- You must be
feeling pretty good
about leadership in
Florida these days,
I mean, obviously we were
together on election night.
DeSantis crushes
it by 20 points,
Rubio wins by 15 points,
something like that.
Like super majority in
the house for Republicans.
We're doing something
right in Florida.
Is that the blueprint for the
rest of the country right now?
- It is.
Let's take a step back,
people need to understand
in Florida a couple things,
one, we have term limits
in our legislature.
So you don't have a situation
where you have members
who have just been around
for a long, long time and
then their own power structure
becomes the navigation
point of your state.
(laughing)
Kinda like it is here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Our legislative seats
roll over all the time,
that's number one.
Number two, everybody
knows Ron DeSantis.
Let's talk Rick
Scott for a moment.
- Yeah.
- Rick Scott,
before he became
governor Rick Scott,
challenger to Mitch
McConnell, Rick Scott,
he was a donor and
he was a businessman.
Completely upset the apple
cart and the Republican party
going back what, 2010?
2010, 2012 was the
time when he came in,
yeah, I think it was 2010.
He completely upset
the apple cart.
The Republican establishment
did not want Rick Scott.
He thought that there was a
better way, he becomes governor.
And so then you
have Ron DeSantis.
He was not the establishment's
choice in Florida,
he becomes governor.
The disruption.
- He was basically
a tea party guy.
The Liberty Caucus.
- He's a freedom caucus.
One of the Freedom
Caucus founders,
tea party conservative,
tea party patriot.
Now he's governor
and everybody says now
he's America's governor.
You know I said that
first by the way.
I'll just put that out.
- Was that you?
Was that you?
- That was me.
- But anyway, but
he's basically,
he's the best governor
in the country.
We all know this.
That is because in Florida,
our political environment
is a meritocracy.
- Mm-hmm.
- That needs to be translated
throughout the United States.
- Do you think other
Red state governors
have the cahones
basically to do it?
I mean, he picks
the right fights,
he's bringing in
the right people.
I always tell people, you
know, from the staff I meet,
it's like these are good people,
but other governors,
they kind of,
they still want the
media to like them,
you know, he bans mainstream
media from events.
Like he's fighting in a
completely different way.
- I don't know, I always
tell people back home,
we have a lot of electeds, we
don't have a lot of leaders.
That's just the
truth of the matter.
Carrie Lake,
you know, it's unfortunate she
didn't get across the line,
but she was in that mold where
she was just gonna be like,
this is what we're doing.
You either like it or you don't,
but it is what needs to happen
for the state of Arizona.
And I think that Arizona,
in my view, is gonna suffer
because they're not gonna
have that type of leadership
which is critical in that state
and frankly in all states.
But are other people capable
of Ron DeSantis type leadership
or Donald Trump type leadership?
- Yeah.
- I think so.
But you have to have an ability
to not be concerned about
what the pundit
class is gonna think.
You have to be willing to go
against the grain sometimes
because you have to look at
the facts, look at the data
and then present the
best option for people,
regardless of what the
apparatus is gonna say,
press is gonna say.
- So you mentioned Trump,
now you're a Trump guy.
- Yeah.
- And you're a DeSantis guy.
You know, it seems like
everyone's just itching
for this fight.
Trump's thrown out a
couple lines on this thing.
I keep telling my audience,
look, I feel like
I win either way
because if DeSantis doesn't run,
he's our governor and
that's freaking great
and then I'll support Trump.
If they both run,
they'll battle it out,
and hopefully it
doesn't get too nasty
and we get a better
candidate out of it.
But what do you
think for people,
'cause I think a lot of
people like 'em both,
partly for the same reasons,
partly for different reasons.
Where does that put you
and what do you think
they need to do?
How about that?
- First and foremost, does
it put me in a bad spot?
Oh yeah.
Because look, I'm
supportive of both men.
They both have been tremendous
in the roles that they've played
in the apparatus
of our politics.
Donald Trump speaks for itself,
our country, and frankly,
Republicans learned
how to stand up
and do the right thing
because of Donald Trump.
- Simply would not have
happened without him.
- Absolute truth.
- Say what you want,
but whether it's Mitt Romney,
John McCain, God rest his soul,
George W. Bush, we
had seen the line of
let's just try to do the
things that are possible,
be leery of the press
'cause they have
more ink in their pen
than you have
words in your mouth
and all that kind
of other stuff.
And Donald Trump broke
that mold and said,
"No, forget all that.
Those people don't even know
what they're talking about.
Do the job and then let
the people see the results
and they'll reward you."
And so he has,
really he is the catalyst for
the new wave of Republican.
But if you're gonna ask me
what I think needs to happen,
Donald Trump's speech
announcing for the presidency
was exactly where
he needs to be.
- Yeah.
The tone was right.
- Pitch perfect.
Talking about his agenda and
talking about his record.
Because beyond a
shadow of a doubt,
he has the very best record
of anybody in the United States.
Stay in that lane,
focus on that.
He's the leader
in the clubhouse.
If that's the Donald Trump you
see for the next 16 months,
he's president of
the United States.
You can go ahead and
book that right now.
- What would you want to happen
between him and the governor
if the governor gets in?
I know it's a little
hypothetical stuff,
but how would you
want it to go down?
I mean, you know, both of them,
do you want it to
all be done publicly?
Do you want them to kind of
have the sit down at Mar-a-Lago.
and figure out how
to work it out?
- I mean, look, I would hope
they would have a sit down
and figure this thing out,
whether that's Mar-a-Lago
or the governor's mansion,
whatever that other place is.
Something tells me to.
- They're too Trump.
- They might wanna
do it in Orlando,
somewhere neutral site or
whatever, I don't know.
But I would hope that
they would work it out.
Now the reality in politics is
sometimes that's
not what happens.
- Yeah.
- So I'm not gonna sit here
and tell you what I
would hope to see,
I'm gonna tell you what
I think I will see.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna be rough.
Just gonna tell you,
it's gonna be rough.
Governor DeSantis has accorded
himself very, very well.
He's led the state of Florida,
biggest win in modern
Florida history.
Nobody thought we would see
election victories
like this in Florida.
He's the tip of
the spear of that.
You gotta give the man credit
for what he has accomplished.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Donald Trump is looking
at this whole thing,
like I'm the one that's
shown everybody how to do it.
- Yeah.
- You know, there's
a old Jay-Z line,
"I show you how to do this son."
(chuckles)
And that's Donald Trump.
And so I think that
that's going be,
there's gonna be some
tough elbows in that race.
Let's just be very clear.
It's gonna get rough.
It's gonna be tough.
But I think at the
end of the day,
both gentlemen understand that
the country is on the line.
Who comes out of that?
Man, Joe Biden might as
well go ahead pack his bags.
I think it's gonna be over.
- Yeah, well, amen to that.
And for the record, unless you
know something I don't know,
we don't even know if
DeSantis wants to run.
I mean, it's just
as simple as that.
Like the guy loves Florida.
That's what people keep saying.
It's like, is he gonna run?
He loves this state.
- Look, I wanna piggyback
on what you just said,
I don't think a decision's
been made on this.
As much as the pundit class
is throwing it out there
and they keep asking
the questions because
it's click bait,
and that's what people
wanna watch and see,
I would rather the
media actually focus
on this FTX debacle
'cause there's some real
stuff going on over there
that has to be uncovered.
But I digress, he has
not made a decision.
Maybe he's made it in his mind,
but nothing's really coming
out, like signaling this,
here we go, here
we go, here we go.
I think we gotta
like pump the breaks.
Donald Trump has now
come out, he's announced.
- Yeah.
- Let Ron DeSantis
take the time whatever
that time might be
to decide what he's going to do,
and then we gonna have plenty
of time for the fireworks.
Trust me.
- Yeah.
- It'll be waiting for us.
- Right, it's very early anyway.
Let me ask you something else
just about being here in DC
and being somewhat new in
Congress and that technically,
you don't look exactly
like what a generic
congressman looks like.
You're black.
- That's right.
- My guys told me
right before you.
- That's what they said.
- We were trying
to figure it out.
- My momma said it.
I came out the womb.
So, you know.
- How does it feel
to be in this,
you know, like when you're
doing your thing in Florida
and it's just kind of working
and then you come
to a place like this
where it's all about the
jockeying and the media
and everything else,
like do you like being here
when you're in DC
doing your thing?
- Sometimes.
Like just to be
straight with you man,
this place is surreal.
Like it's still surreal that
I'm here, that I'm doing this.
- Yeah.
- I told my colleagues,
after this conference
chair thing,
"They were like, man, you
know, it didn't work out.
How do you feel?"
And I'm like, "Are
you kidding me?"
If you look at my life going
up from Brooklyn, New York,
all the struggles
I've been through
to being in the room doing this.
- Yeah.
- Man,
I'm playing with
house money man.
So that part is ecstatic for me.
- Yeah.
- Now
just keeping it real,
'cause this is what I do.
The petty backstabbing
stuff in DC,
man, I don't like
that kind of stuff.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Like I'm a man.
If you feel a
certain way, say it.
I will respect you if you do.
I don't do all the back
talk, backstabbing stuff,
I don't like that stuff.
I'm very diplomatic and I'm a
genuine person, I'm very nice.
I respect everybody 'cause
I want people to respect me.
I'm here about business,
I'm here to fight
for the country,
I'm here to win for the country.
But all these little petty
games, Dave, I'm not that guy.
- Yeah.
- That is not me.
I'm still a kid from
Brooklyn, New York.
(chuckles)
I'm a kid from the streets.
- Yeah.
- Who has matured through life,
built a career,
engaged in politics.
I just want to, let's do
business, and let's go home.
We not always gonna
like each other,
we're not always gonna
agree with each other.
And that's fine.
Yeah, but let's do business,
let's make sure it gets
done for the people.
All the petty stuff, eh,
not a big fan of that.
- Two guys born in Brooklyn
fighting in the free state
of Florida, pretty cool.
I got, all right,
two more for you
and then we'll let you go.
So just talk to me real quick
about what's going on with
the hurricane recovery.
Because as I told people,
you are the congressman for,
I mean, you got hit, that is
your home area right there.
What's the latest?
- It's gonna be tough
sledding on our beaches.
Our beaches were hit
really, really hard.
That's what's gonna take
two years in my opinion.
- Yeah.
- To rebuild.
Now I want to caution everybody,
most of Southwest Florida
is back up and running.
You know, our restaurants are
open, our businesses are open,
hotels, Airbnbs,
you know, I think some of
the boat rentals and stuff,
you could still
probably get your boats
and get out to certain places.
Some of the places are still
gonna have to be repaired.
But Southwest, Florida is open,
people are flying in and
out right now as we speak.
- [Rubin] Yeah, yep.
- But our barrier
islands, our beaches,
they're gonna take
some time to recover.
In Fort Myers beach
specifically, in
Sanibel, Benita beach.
The beach in Naples.
We're gonna redo some stuff,
but we'll be back on track,
it's gonna be fine.
It's just gonna take
time and some patience.
Now I think we have the
leadership to get that done.
Obviously Governor DeSantis
at the head of that
has been phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- Our local leadership
has done a tremendous job.
FEMA, SBA, we've been
working in concert with them.
Everybody is pulling forward.
It's just gonna take
time to get it back.
- Were there any major
screw ups with this thing?
'Cause it felt like it was
just as disastrous as it was
that it was just kind
of clean and obviously,
the governor gets a
lot of credit for that,
but FEMA,
there are federal agencies
that came in and helped too.
- Well, listen, first of
all, in terms of screw ups,
the way the press
likes to talk about it.
- Well, 'cause
they were waiting,
they wanted something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This is a problem
with the press,
they do this stuff all the time.
The reality is that storm,
and I remember I was at the
National Hurricane Center
'cause I was here in DC
when the storm made landfall
and the modelers were
telling me directly,
it was tough to predict
the track on this storm
because it kept,
they call it jogging,
like it kept moving from here
to there, to here to there.
And it just kept jogging,
I think it was Tuesday,
late Monday into Tuesday
before that storm hit.
We had people who
evacuated from Tampa Bay
in Fort Myers.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they were shocked
when they basically
were in the epicenter
of the storm
because all the modeling
had showed Tampa Bay,
Sarasota County.
And so that's kind
of what happened.
It was tough, but I think
in terms of response,
in terms of preparedness
and response, top notch.
- All right, I got
one more for you,
what do you wanna do
after being congressman
for a couple of terms?
What's the plan man?
We're in DC, we have a governor
who might move on to
some other things.
There's all sorts of
interesting opportunities.
And also a Republican party
that's obviously
in flux right now
and needs some new voices.
What do you think about that?
- When I left the State House,
some of my colleagues said,
"Would you ever come back?"
And I said, "I'm only
coming back one way."
- Ah.
- I'll leave it at that.
- All right, I
like it, I like it.
Good seeing you, man.
- Good seeing you.
- All right.
If you're looking
(intense ambient music)
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.